hello the Internet I'm gay I'm done
where the slow mo guys one of my
favorite channels very high production
value corridor digital I like it it's a
good channel even the second channels
good so what I'm gonna do is just Nick
one of their ideas at least you're being
upfront yeah I saw them try and slice an
arrow in half with a katana and it
looked pretty cool that sort of medium
slo-mo yeah I figured why don't we just
super slow-mo yeah I'm gonna have to be
firing the arrow you're gonna have to do
the shopping yeah doesn't reset the
Phantom I did archery it beavers or
something beavers oh you're gonna find
off now all right okay oh I've already
all right oh that is gone that goes at
some clip that I'm so I still have lost
my confidence in you being able to do it
now oh really yes well I don't really
have any control other than I get to go
do some micro polls but really once it's
locked in that's like a set speed isn't
it yeah you have to aim that nicely so I
can actually hit it because otherwise
I'm gonna be just going collecting
arrows how many attempts do you think it
will take you to sever it right in the
middle of the arrow a clean clean cut
yeah I reckon like 30 times
how many arrows do we have we've got six
we've got six yeah I I kind of didn't
really think about it that much
just get one yeah one hour yeah yeah
right you know if I miss it it won't
break all right let's set the Phantom
all right and start what could be a very
long process of trying to get this shot
all right okay so we're gonna do a few
things because there's no one on the
Phantom I'm gonna have the trigger on a
wire in my pocket and just so Dan
doesn't get skewered through the guts
these are sort of rubber tipped training
arrows that would probably hurt but not
go in to Dan all right Dan goggles on
gloves on yep then you can hit the
target I don't know about that okay
let's see flip your neck that really
goes in and all don't hit me with that
thing
I'll try not to okay all right if you
get on the first attempt to save us all
a lot of time yeah I'm off screen
because there I need to be far enough
away that Dan can see or I'm gonna count
you down there whoo
this is gonna be hard work I could tell
already three two one fire
I got it I got it trigger I got it what
I nailed it
I got the front we got the frame I got
the front what I got it wait I got it
wait I got it clean wait I got it clean
me what what did I get it all right pack
it up
so I bought six we needed one excellent
there we go
that was my test one there was your test
one and then you got it on the next one
yeah oh it's like got my eye in and
we're done I thought to be a longer
video because it took oral guys a few
guys we got here so early for this we
have like hours left
oh we can just try again get a close-up
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that's delicious either I was gonna miss
or you deflected the arrow away from the
target
yeah wait so I like sliced I think you
weren't missing I think you were yeah
you deflate for the arrow it bounced up
and then the flights kicked in again
it's stabilized and continued higher
than the target we could have used real
arrows with somebody stood there well I
think the tip would have still hit like
today if span and like went in backwards
to be fair you did make a nice clean
sever that would have really hurt still
oh yeah well that's true story you like
the guy behind me who I'm like
protecting so you'd be like I'll be
would be stood there with the tip of the
arrow like people be like he would be
like how did that happen like what
happened I can't believe that thanks
that's pretty good of it I hear that
that was wicked yeah so the tip landed
here right and that's that's how I know
I got it properly because I I sliced
felt a very small amount of resistance
and I looked around and I saw the tip
wow what a clean slice isn't it
so this is where it hit and then bounced
off onto the floor oh this pot isn't
quite so clean and there's a small shard
of it that's come off the back there
that part is marries up with the front
and there's like a small bit of like
wood that's come off I'd also hit the
ground a lot you know with a lot more
force could it's still sailing away oh
that's probably the chipping here but
this second part I'm sure that came off
in the slo-mo we can see that little
extra chip come off okay this time for a
close-up I'm gonna try to fire right
past the Phantom and I start to shoot it
and then we'll try and get a much closer
shot of you doing the exact same thing
if you can I'll try I imagine if it
actually hits me it's got a bloody earth
yeah but it would be a nice Bruce
I just trust you here all right yeah all
right ready yeah three two one fire
got it oh I got the back of it you got
it I got the back of it you know what I
have actually slightly worried at how
close to the lens I put that I must have
missed that by a few inches
eyes on the prize I see that when you
still got it to the gut at least he
didn't get to the shoulder yeah that was
actually really nice positioning of the
weather here because all the feathers
are coming off info oh yeah it's like
loads of actual feathers just like
splinted everywhere what you need is a
directly in the middle and hopefully
just like in Armageddon they'll miss the
target oh yeah
just like that asteroid missed the earth
we've got two hours left I think you're
asking a bit much it all right the
weather's taking a turn we're losing
light we might get rained on in a bit
but before that happens let's try and
get one more same angle I like that
angle okay just try and get a more
central hit I know it's asking a lot all
right I'll try three two one fire
got it got this got the end again damn
it how much time do you think
distance-wise there is between there and
there time time point zero zero
something of a second so it seems like a
miles out but I'm point bugger all yeah
I would say that I would say the
difference between here and here could
be measured in milliseconds probably
it's going pretty fast we could probably
calculate how quickly fast yeah how
quick that is we can calculate it on the
white yeah three two one fire I got it
at the back again damn it wow that was a
really nasty cut
was it yeah I sliced it really finely
there how was it you made it so that
each end of the arrow sort hit him flat
ah and the top half deviate away well we
ran out of arrows quite quickly because
you were so damn good at getting him I
need I got them from the beginning and
sort of a middle oh yeah and the end I'd
like to think that you could I'd like to
think that you could stand behind me on
a battlefield and be all right yeah I
would stand behind you yeah yeah I'd
probably take it instead of here I take
you like here in here yeah that the
further
would you hit on the arrow it would
always deviate the arrow but if there
was enough of the arrow left the
furthest could still cause the rifling
to the point where it would just
stabilize again but on a different on a
different path also because of the
weight of the arrows is that the front
the the further forward the the slice
was the cleaner the cut because
obviously the weight is behind the cut
whereas is less weight behind the cut
and it's sort of easily movable so it's
gonna be much less there are much more
splintery yeah and long cuts to the back
yeah if you see the comparison there
between the front and the back so we
pretty much can't film anymore because
hey we're a barrows and B is a big old
storm rolling that's about to blow all
of our equipment away well that's not
the only reason there is a see there's a
reason see that's why we're stopping
filming and I sort of sort of shot the
monitor you destroyed the mana for this
slo-mo camera so we can't actually shoot
anymore that's the big reason why we
can't shoot it's because we've set we've
got a full video on the monitor carnage
over on the second channel so make sure
you check that out if you like seeing
things that are expensive and useful
destroyed
we just don't usually break equipment on
this channel surprising poison it's very
well that's the first loss of equipment
since the classic GoPro Canon incident
[Music]
wait that means we're even you won all
but mine was a GoPro yeah and yours was
that mine was a several thousand dollar
small HD monitor yeah how all right make
sure you go and check out the video over
there because we need to buy a new
monitor yeah I subscribe and watch the
video well tell 9 friends yeah yeah it's
a funded new monitor guys they've broken
some equipment alright thank you very
much for watching we'll see you in the
next video
love and kisses I think I was born in
the wrong time you'd have been an
excellent Japanese man from the past